as the number of coronavirus cases
continues to swell in the US models
project infections in some of the worst
hit American cities New York New Orleans
and Detroit are at or near their peak I
don't know if we can bend the curve in
Detroit they fail to do it in New York
and the the loss of life is almost
unimaginable
we know our hospital systems are so
overwhelmed just access to care is not
as easy as it was before I see a lot of
you know potential for bad outcomes
virus related deaths in Wayne County
where Detroit is are the highest in the
u.s. outside of New York City and Nassau
County which is also in New York there
is a truism in epidemiology that the
people who suffer the most tend to be
the poorest and the most marginalized in
the society no matter what the society
is no matter what the disease is Detroit
a city slow to recover from the 2008
financial crisis is fighting again
this time against the coronavirus so how
is the city responding and will Detroit
prove more vulnerable to this crisis
when you think about an epidemic often
we always look at the pathogen and
that's just part of the story the other
part of the story is the host and the
environment dr. Abdul Assad has an
epidemiologists who previously served as
the health director for the city of
Detroit he says underlying
vulnerabilities in the city have fueled
the increase in Detroit scope in 19
cases Detroit unfortunately in so many
circumstances has been the hardest hit
by a number of dynamics that
disproportionately affect low-income
people and people of color in our
country more than a third of people in
Detroit live in poverty and the
prevalence of underlying health
conditions such as diabetes asthma and
heart problems are much higher there
than elsewhere in the country all of
those things create a community that is
uniquely vulnerable the outbreak has
been particularly fatal for the state's
black residents who make up 40% of
Michigan's reported deaths but only 14%
of the state's total population the city
of Detroit where most of the state's
cases are is majority black
hey dr. Asha here and getting ready to
go to the Pope Francis Center dr. Asha
shajahan is a family medicine physician
and medical director of community health
at Beaumont Grosse Pointe she's been
treating kovat patients via telemedicine
and volunteers three days a week at the
Pope Francis Center a homeless service
provider in Detroit about to get started
with my day some homeless service
providers in Detroit have been forced to
close or reduce services to adhere to
government guidelines think about all
the things that we're telling people to
do at home stay at home they don't have
a home to stay in wash your hands where
are they gonna have access to wash their
hands with soap you know for 20 seconds
dr. Shah Jahan's screens patients for
kovat like symptoms and if necessary
refers them to a city facility where
they can isolate and receive further
medical attention we need to take care
of everybody and if patients don't have
the ability to get screened then they're
potentially spreading it to others and
putting themselves at risk the Pope for
instance Center has shifted operations
outdoors so that guests have access to
water soap and medical attention while
socially distancing we have hand-washing
stations available for the patients we
know that poverty and health go hand in
hand many of the patients that I see
they already have asthma they already
have COPD they already have mental
health issues so having the anxiety of
kovat in addition to everything else
that's going on puts them at higher risk
Mayor Mike Duggan has pushed back on the
idea that the city's poverty contributed
to it being a hot spot I spoke to dr.
mark service this morning who was also
deeply disturbed by this coverage and he
said there is no evidence that the
corona virus checks your bank account I
do agree that the corona virus does not
doesn't look at people's pockets but I
do think there are people there at
higher risk of contracting the virus
because of their comorbidities it's not
only just the elderly but it's also
people that you know are at higher risk
because of their social circumstances as
Detroit residents worried about staying
healthy the impact this corona virus
will have on the city's economy is still
unclear
for a city that has seen an economic
crisis before some fear the effects will
be felt long after this public health
crisis is over unfortunately you know
this is sort of a sucker punch that
comes right at a moment where folks felt
like the worst was behind us and it's
hard to it's hard to see I mean
everyone's doing good staying safe we'll
be back on Monday